has ego been bad or good for you oh gosh
I think it's been I think I'm so
thankful for
ego
um
dude does it
get off the Bridle for me sometimes and
run loose and run places and where
it's
not of service to others and has it to
hurt loved ones and even strangers yes
um
but I I also
when my ego is really strong
it's
it's in sync
with serving it's in sync with
where I serve myself
also serve as others serves others it's
those two are part and parcel they're
they're they're they're they're
intertwined
and that's the capital E ego that I
think I think and hope we all need more
of and that's what I mean when I talk
about selfish that's to redefining that
the real true meaning of that is not
doing something for self at expense of
your neighbor or harming others it's
for personal profit and pleasure that
also is profit and pleasure for
a utilitarian sends more
of others
and there's a there's again back to the
Paradox that I think there's a place I
know there's a place I believe there's a
place where those are in sync and when
my ego's healthy
um
I'm able to
say I'm sorry sooner for a lie or a
misdemeanor or harm somebody I'm able to
be more empathetic
because I got the confidence yeah
to be so I'm able to be more humble
but still have my chin High I'm a hard
high and look in the eye and go
yep my bad bogey guilty
I shank that one out of bounds man
that's beautiful so ego can be
constructive not destructive